President Trump says he has a new
strategy to fight the 16 year old war in
Afghanistan one way or another these
problems will be solved I'm a problem
solver and in the end we will win the
president used a prime-time speech in
front of US troops last night to suggest
more Americans will be sent to the war
zone now that's a big reversal from his
position as a candidate mr. Trump
insisted his support for the embattled
Afghan government is not open-ended
major Garrett is at the White House with
how the president hopes to succeed where
the last two US presidents struggled
major good morning good morning for
years Donald Trump told America
Afghanistan was a waste of time blood
and treasure but after months of
discussions with the Pentagon and the
CIA the president Trump will not only
stay in Afghanistan but increased the US
troop presence now there was talk of a
harder line against Afghan corruption in
Pakistan's welcome mat to terror groups
but very few specifics and even fewer
benchmarks the American people are weary
of war without victory the president
confided to a military audience and the
nation that a complete withdrawal from
Afghanistan was a real option
my original instinct was to pull out and
historically I like following my
instincts but all my life I've heard
that decisions are much different when
you sit behind the desk in the Oval
Office President Trump said he inherited
a bad and very complex hand but that the
risks of abandoning Afghanistan were too
high terrorists who slaughter innocent
people will find no glory in this life
or the next
they are nothing but thugs and criminals
and predators and that's right losers
like presidents before him mr. Trump
complained about Pakistan's tolerance of
terror cells and he fretted about
Pakistan's tensions with India Pakistan
often gives safe haven to agents of
chaos
violence and terror the threat is worse
because Pakistan and India are two
nuclear-armed States significantly the
president did not specify how many
troops he will send to Afghanistan
advisers say the number could rise to
four thousand but with the fighting
season expected to end this fall their
impact may not be seen until 2018 I will
not say when we are going to attack but
attack we will mr. Trump walked a fine
line between open-ended commitment and a
new deadline for withdrawal
we are not nation-building again we are
killing terrorists
however our commitment is not unlimited
and our support is not a blank check
NATO nations are also expected to
provide more troops and a bit more
financing the White House said
repeatedly this new strategy will be
judged on its results not held to a
timeline but asked to describe what
quote winning will look like one senior
advisor said only we will know what
progress looks like bill no only see it
major Garrett thank you the